president trump said i had the right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong the third
hearing of the january 6 select
committee focused on the pressure faced
by former vice president mike pence from
his boss and pence's refusal to comply
we are fortunate for mr pence's courage
on january 6th
our democracy came dangerously close to
catastrophe multiple witnesses testified
that trump wanted pence to ignore state
electors casting votes for joe biden and
simply pick the president himself an
action that according to this
conservative former federal judge would
have plunged america into a revolution
within a constitutional crisis
i would have laid my body
across the road before
i would have let
the vice president
overturn the
2020 election
the proposal described by some as a
blueprint for a coup was crafted by
former trump attorney john eastman he
would later admit his plan would not
survive a legal challenge and on
thursday lawmakers revealed he sought a
presidential pardon
another former trump attorney said
eastman's plan left him aghast
i said are you out of your f in mind i
said you're completely crazy i said
you're going to turn around
and tell
78 plus million people in this country
that your
theory is this is how you're going to
invalidate their votes because you think
the election was stolen
other witnesses said on the morning of
january 6 trump called pence to once
again push to overturn the election
white house aides and trump's daughter
told investigators they overheard
trump's end of the call
either he called him a wimp i don't
remember he said you are a whim the
conversation was was
pretty heated apologize for being
impolite but do you remember what she
said her father called him
the p word
trump would then appear on stage at a
rally near the capitol ad-libbing these
comments about his vice president and
mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
trump's followers listened
and erected a gallows outside the
capitol
witnesses said trump was informed of the
growing violence and urged to calm the
situation but instead he tweeted mike
pence didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done to protect our
country and our constitution
the rioters surged immediately after and
secret service moved pence to an
underground location barely missing
rioters by meters he would shelter from
the mob for more than four hours as more
than 100 police officers were injured
and several rioters died finally he
would return to the senate floor joining
congress to finish certifying joe
biden's win
trump has called these hearings
treasonous at least another three are
planned the committee saying they will
focus on trump's efforts to corrupt the
justice department and his actions to
summon the mob
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington